by the power of gasol hate skull i am
hella mark harley and today we are
talking to a man named sterling cooper
he's one of my favorite youtubers he's a
former male porn star and male escort
and before you halt your horses and say
whoa whoa whoa i didn't sign up for that
kind of
illicit material in my feed
hold on a second because if you're a guy
if you're someone who strives to be more
masculine more competent in the bedroom
more dominant at life i think sterling
might have a lot to teach you i know
i've certainly learned a lot from him
he's got over 500 youtube videos and
each one of them is both entertaining
and informative and he's got some cool
courses online that he'll also tell you
about so without further ado here is my
super interesting conversation with
sterling cooper uh i am in fact very
excited today to have sterling cooper on
the podcast you are one of the you know
when when i decided to start having
guests on here and i i put down a list
of people i'd say you were probably
the top three or four um
just as a consumer of your content i
think it's great i think it's
informative i think it's dynamic and
interesting and
i credit you as one of these
people who kind of drew me into what i
would call the manosphere loosely
although
there might be better terms to describe
it but
it's like this male self-improvement
with an edge of
sexuality and more so in your case
because i think you get right to the
point of like
teaching sex as a as a skill that you
can learn right which i think is a big
important thing to uh
learning how to be masculine but also it
doesn't stop there it's just general
it overlaps into self-help and sort of
psychology i guess how to be a more
masculine effective competent man in
general and what i love about guys like
you is you've been in the trenches so
when i pitch you to people i was telling
brendan he's like who's this guy i'm
like well he's a porn star but like i'm
not coming to him as a fan of you know
like i love you as a porn star it's like
he just
he has the reps of of being around women
and knowing exactly how to navigate
every situation
uh that has to deal with women and i
think that has a lot of overlap to just
succeeding in life because you're going
to get tested and you're going to doubt
yourself and uh you know you you've got
to learn some strategies so without
further ado sterling cooper maybe you
could talk more about yourself to sum it
up better than i did
well look thank you for having me on
mark and uh and happy birthday you told
me before we went live that it is your
birthday thank you yes i appreciate it
don't want to uh you know miss out on
that and as i said i'm very happy to be
spending with you because i love doing
something on my birthday that feels like
you know so if you would have told me a
year ago you're going to be zooming with
sterling cooper i would have been like
shut up you're crazy that's impossible
but here i am
well it took us long enough to get this
uh organized but yeah very patiently
yeah sometimes that'll just drop off you
miss a couple times and have to
reschedule then it's like you just never
hear from the person so i do appreciate
uh the tenacity that you showed and
showing up
and thank you for having me on it man
it's a pleasure yeah yeah uh for anyone
who's not really familiar with with me
and my work
i'm i'm sterling cooper i am
an award-winning adult film star porn
star you call me that and i also used to
be a high-class male companion back in
australia used to get paid to uh service
wealthy business women yeah that's how i
like to put it
yeah and now i i've i take
that experience of shall we say
performing under pressure uh you know
having sex in high pressure scenarios
and i
take my learnings and my teachings and
my insights from that and i help guys in
the bedroom yeah and i help them you
know and you mentioned this just a
second ago i think there's a there's a
strong kind of correlation
between
the dynamic in the bedroom and the
dynamic outside the bedroom within a
relationship
yeah yeah if a guy is
you know
embracing his his true masculine nature
in the bedroom i think that massively
reflects outside the bedroom and it
gives guys this
edge you know this this sexy edge
this uh
you know no [ __ ] this
what we might define specifically as a
masculine edge about them when they
interact with women in general because
if you kind of if you kind of know that
you can rock a girl's world
in the bedroom it translates like the
way you look at a girl is totally
different the way you talk to a girl is
totally different and they can pick up
on that instantly and i think it's a
really good place for guys to to dive
into and and hone their skills
which will like
it's a hell of a lot of fun when you
know what you're doing in the bedroom
and you can and you can perform well and
you can you know rock a world and then
it translates outside the bedroom you
know you can kind of what there's a
reason why they have the expression big
dick energy
i was just gonna say that actually
because
that is true and that word gets thrown a
lot around a lot today but i do think
there's something to it because it sort
of means sexual confidence and
let's think about the opposite for a
second
when a guy has small dick energy um
and maybe you could have a big dick or
not but it sort of it does imply sexual
incompetence and it also kind of
connotes really somebody
overcompensating you know or or
perhaps giving some sort of signal to
the world that he wouldn't be confident
under pressure or when it counts in the
bedroom etc and
um as you were speaking i was thinking
about
most men probably don't understand the
pressures that a porn star faces and and
if you've ever been in any alternative
sex situation like i've you know
been in a room with more than one person
having sex and the immediate
uptick of stress that goes on and you're
like oh wow getting an erection is no
longer you know a given right you have
to have focus
and
i think
i remember hearing from a director who
used to film real couples and maybe it
was even something related to your
content i'm trying to dig back to what
it was or maybe like a holly randle
podcast but it was whole i think you
talked about holly randall i think it's
right yeah so and she said it was like
an 80 percent of guys couldn't do it
right and it was a very normal thing
that you'd be like hey you want to you
know it's every guy's dream be a porn
star you know but when it comes you know
push comes to shove and it's time to
perform
uh because think about it if you're in
the bedroom and something maybe you know
you get a phone call that you know debt
collectors are after you it's like try
getting a direction after that or
something you know right so this sudden
uptick in stress so when i think about
what you did and where you've been as a
male escort and thinking
for example this morning i was in the
shower going man it is such
a world of difference
uh as a male a skirt versus a female
escort because you are
not only is the pressure to actually
achieve and attain an erection
physically but also
the entire experience of making that
woman feel comfortable and still
seducing her and charming her in a sense
because unlike women where a guy might
hire her and it's just like hey show up
take your clothes off i'm going to do my
thing and this can be over in 10 minutes
as a male escort there's just much more
impetus on you to provide
a thorough experience from start to
finish that makes the woman feel you
know very comfortable and loved and
excited and all these different emotions
and kind of like a male stripper seeing
this documentary on male strippers oh
they got to create a whole character
they're picking women up on stage it's
like they earn their money you know it's
not just go up there and flash your tits
and maybe you could start there
you know i would be interested to hear
how you got into it but i would just say
whatever is the most interesting part of
that experience for you and some
takeaways for guys
well you're right in the sense that it's
not just
the the male escorts job is about
selling this sort of fantasy and this
and providing this experience right the
boyfriend experience
and it's
not so much about specifically what
you're doing in the bedroom obviously
that is a that is happening at the end
of the night but
two-thirds of the entire interaction or
three-quarters of the entire interaction
with her is the whining and dining
experience the romancing the
you have to think about the the kind of
woman who is going to hire a male escort
typically my typical client
she's
mid-30s
uh
six-figure earner or multiple six-figure
owner like
career business woman
she
can't get
on a date with the kind of man she wants
to go on a date with yeah like so let's
let's you know maybe guys who are kind
of like her peers in her career because
those guys are dating like 18 19 20 year
old chicks right
so she is looking for the kind of guy
who's sort of at her level her age
like good looking in shape
charming and woody
but unfortunately those guys aren't
going after her so my job is to come in
and step in and make her feel loved
again to make her feel
like she is beautiful to make her feel
like i like to say like i i like to make
them feel like they're the only woman in
the world
everyone everyone every other woman on
the planet is completely invisible to me
while i am there with her
and
a lot of guys might confuse that
uh that with like simpy behavior right a
lot of guys might because because
there's a nuance to this right there's
there's the guy who's
fawning over a woman and
blowing smoke up her ass and telling her
she's she's beautiful and she's gorgeous
and she could do no wrong but she ain't
actually attracted to that guy yeah
and then there's the guy she is
attracted to who she who she does
respect
and then when that guy
tells her she's beautiful or when that
guy pays attention undivided attention
to her
all of a sudden her panties get wet and
there's a big difference between those
two men right and so it's my job to be
that i mean i am that guy but it's also
my job to sort of to be that guy to
women that i might not necessarily
do that to on on during my personal life
right so i can create i can dive into
that character and create that
experience for her and if i'm being
honest like
this
kind of landed it kind of lends hand in
hand with my ability to act as a porn
star as well like the acting side of
pawn right because i'm you're living it
it's not like
for for the entirety of that booking i
am that guy i am i am believing
that i'm into this this woman
and i'm believing that interaction
myself because if i believe it then
she's going to believe it
yeah
yeah and that's not hard to imagine
because i do as i mentioned before your
content is very entertaining in the
manner in which you speak your word
selection your rhythm all these stuff as
a performer you know as an actor myself
i go this guy's got it and so you you
have those skills but
also i just think there's so much human
insight into what you're saying because
it's like three different categories of
things as you mentioned where it's like
one thing is to bombard a woman with
praise in which you're simping for her
and going from a submissive position and
in
my limited coaching to other men because
sometimes guys would just come to me and
say hey what is this what do you think
about this text that i sent to somebody
and it's this block of text and they're
saying my queen uh i want to come over
and cook you any meal you want and i
bought you this gift and i'm like you
met this girl on tinder last night you
know yeah this you shouldn't be sending
her a message as if if it's
your wife of 10 years and you're trying
to reinv whatever is going on there so
that's one thing learning how to be
um
be her fantasy from a position of
leadership where you're making her feel
like she's the only girl in the world
but but balance that out and i know this
is something i've heard you talk about
in a few different videos
still instilling
or having the frame of a guy who has
options competition anxiety and stuff
like that that's a whole different
conversation maybe but
you have to be giving this woman
attention but simultaneously looking
acting presenting yourself as a guy who
if you looked at other girls
they would be interested in you too and
you're shutting that right and that's
something that a lot of guys get
confused i think is
when a girl says i want a nice guy what
she means is
i want this [ __ ] who i'm attracted to
to be nicer to me
they're not thinking of the guy she
doesn't she doesn't want uh being more
nice but it's just a very common
misconception out there because we hear
that so much so mainstream
the idea is you can sort of nice your
way into a girl's panties but it doesn't
really work like that you have to be
confident and you have to be bold but
also hyper focused on that woman and
just be able to i mean i think empathy
plays into this because i know when i
was younger i didn't understand how you
know it's like well it if i'm looking
good isn't that all a woman wants or you
have these things that we're attracted
to women because they show up and look
at her party i'm like okay well if i
look good too shouldn't that drop their
panties and you're like no that's that's
a tiny little slice that's great and all
but you really have to get into the mind
of a woman and see things from her
perspective but a lot of things
in that regard or counterintuitive
uh you know to what a man thinks and so
have you always been
uh good with women or is this something
that you
learned through experience
i had to learn it through experience
yeah i was honest to god when i was when
i was a teenager i was a geek i was a
complete
complete nerd when i was a teenager like
scrawny uh
i was athletic i played basketball my
whole life but i was uh
yeah definitely definitely like like top
like a grade top of the class no joke
like top of my top my class uh kind of
geek and uh
after my i had like a relationship for
like three years from like high school
through to university
and when that fell apart i i'm like okay
i'm kind of like a man now
and i didn't really understand anything
about women and i was what was like like
19 20 probably like 19. yeah and so i
had to kind of like
learn a lot of that through my
university years and after graduating
university just like
meeting up with other guys learning of
other guys going out to clubs and bars
like
there was a space of a period of time
where i went out like seven nights a
week every night
not not drinking either like stone cold
sober just talking to chicks trying to
like
develop those social skills and get a
better understanding of human human
interactions and then
it paid off because i ended up you know
slinging dick for a living
uh one of one of the things i'll say on
the point you made a second ago
is consider it like
that idea of of being a man with options
right that idea of abundance of having
abundance yeah think of it from a
woman's perspective if a guy
who doesn't have any options at all
gives her praise
well then it's it's kind of meaningless
like his his attention and his
validation is kind of meaningless
versus a guy who clearly has abundance
and clearly has options if he tells her
she's beautiful or that actually means
something
yeah his attention and his validation
and his respect actually have weight to
it compared to the other guy yeah and
attention as a currency i think is a
concept that i've been thinking about a
lot more lately
and maybe you know this intuitively
after
you've had enough experience with women
but you can
you know so attention is this finite
currency that obviously women are
competing for from men but also you can
add value to your
attention as an individual by becoming
uh higher value and uh and making that
actually worth something and that as
you're saying comes from
uh
having other people sort of or looking
like a guy or appearing or living as a
guy who uh who whose attention people
value right and so it's interesting
about the
this time that you spent in bars and
clubs because i think the first time i
was introduced to the idea of pickup you
know in 2005 reading the game or
whatever and this notion of just going
out and getting these reps and of course
that makes intuitive sense because he's
like all right it's like football it's
like a sport it's you just gotta put in
these thousand hours
although
it's cool nowadays it's this community
has seemed to morph into like hey don't
go out there and just lie to women all
the time or that's like sure use that as
practice but ultimately
the real thing should be becoming that
guy right becoming the guy who is
excellent who is confident who is
actually
a high-value masculine man and so when
he says these things and approaches in a
certain way it's authentic right um but
how long did it take you to sort of
master this to go from being a dork
a self-described right geek to to
feeling like you you had an
understanding of how to uh approach and
interact with women without any anxiety
because i think that's what most guys
what prevents most guys from doing that
in the first place is it's tremendously
anxiety inducing to approach women who
you don't know
yeah it probably took me a good a couple
of years
very good good two years have consistent
of just consistent effort grinding yeah
and obviously during that time i had i
had girlfriends and i was going you know
you know i was having success but after
about a couple after like a couple of
years it really started to sort of it
wasn't a thing i was doing anymore it
was who i was it solidified in my head
yeah now that i i
i kind of think of it as like
a calming
right like it's just this calm energy
around like
the nervousness around women was
replaced with just being calm yeah
i remember actually uh trying
when i was first
kind of trying to use some of the things
that i learned in
the game or whatever in my early 20s and
you know i looking back it's like man
you just
there's so many things about being in
your early 20s at a guy as a guy that
are a disadvantage but i remember going
into certain social situations
with higher energy that was then was
needed when you kind of come in and
you're like hey what's up like there's a
time and a place for it but you're
almost like
in my mind a mistake was thinking that
you kind of have to be entertaining to
somebody as if you're honest like i'm
going to come in and i'm going to crack
a joke and turn to you and be kind of
almost bordering on manic in order to
get women to be attracted to you or be
captivating but the truth is almost the
opposite as you're saying the more you
can calm yourself down because
that signals to somebody
that you know in part something we've
talked about high value because this is
nothing to you talking to people and a
beautiful woman doesn't
escalate your heart rate
right which is the first step in sort of
the physical manifestation of stress so
if you can approach a beautiful woman
who who's used to men being nervous
around her with a calm energy
i think it conveys a lot to women so
maybe you could talk about that
think about
the
what causes nervousness in social
interactions
we are always
if you look if let's say you're in a
room with a celebrity
yeah and there's a group of people
around that celebrity all listening to
him
he is usually the most calm
person in the room and everybody else
is
emotionally reacting to him yeah
he says something everyone else bursts
out to laughter or they start to fidget
with their body they can't sort of
control like they're touching their face
at them you know fiddling with their
hands or something like that right
so the idea of the way i think about it
is the idea of how calm you can be
in a social interaction or
in an interaction with women
tells you or tells her rather
how
hard it is for people to emotionally
affect you yeah
and that the ability to be unaffected
emotionally is a big signal of status
yeah
right because the person at the very the
person who's the most nervous the most
you know the most nervous the most
fidgety the most awkward
is typically the person with the lowest
status in a social interaction yeah yeah
the person who's calm and collected
and
uh
has confidence in what they're saying
again tends to have the higher status in
an interaction that's a really
interesting way to put it that i think
i've often associated
uh
my
own attitudes on stoicism with
masculinity right and i love that maybe
you know i i feel like i deal with
certain stresses pretty well or things
i've seen you know i love it when you're
with a girl and they freak out you're
just like i got this babe you know it's
a great thing to do right but
pairing it with status is a really
interesting observation
um that i find to be very true and i do
think that is sort of this cornerstone
of masculinity and status as like a big
chunk is just how you react to things
because i do think i always
try to remind guys
we are not that long removed from living
in tribes
uh from being in situations where when
that saber-toothed tiger comes up you
know you can't as a guy be going ah
right you gotta be i'm gonna handle this
right and whatever situation but we're
not that far removed from
sort of daily life and death situations
in which men are expected
to confront the problem uh with a cool
head with uh without fear uh without
running away without [ __ ] their
pants and uh there are ways to convey
that
which is a very
primal you know lizard braid signifier
to the people around you
you know that you are confident
masculine high value and are somebody
who you should stick closely to right
um so i've never really paired that in
my you know as far as status but it's
it's totally true and the celebrity
thing i was going to say neil brennan
has this joke about
being around celebrities you can pretend
like it doesn't affect you
like when you're driving next to a cop
it's like you can pretend like you're
driving normally
but everyone is stressed out i've never
related to something more in life i'm
like god damn it's so true you see a
copy and you're just like nothing wrong
here no weed in my pocket everything's
fine um
but the truth is you're kind of freaking
out and i've noticed that a lot more
lately when i've seen people interact
with maybe people who are celebrities
that that i know or interact with more
and then uh you see
how even grown men will kind of become
like little emotional reactive girls um
and it's obviously a subconscious effect
but that's a great way of putting it the
people around you are emotionally
reacting to you and
and i think that's it's one of the best
ways that you can actually
network
and like stand out in networking with
with really successful men like
wealthy men you know celebrities people
of competence people of success
one of the easiest ways to stand out and
actually befriend them and network with
them is by by just staying calm and not
right you know not acting like a goddamn
fanboy right the skill of having a
normal conversation with somebody high
value
that is not to be underlooked and it's
something that i think about often and
never if i you know i have a rule about
going never ask somebody for a picture
or this or that or or kind of treat them
you know also just on a human level
because i go i don't you know if you
were that person would you want to be
sort of treated like an object who
you're going to pose with for a picture
no of course not any you don't want to
have an annoying conversation where
somebody tells you their life story and
how big of a family where they just want
to have a
normal minimalistic conversation and
remember you don't know this person
right
and what what the internet does is it
creates this phenomenon of familiarity
yeah so if you're on the internet in any
way like i'm on the internet youtube and
i'm also on the internet on various
other
yeah sites yeah i imagine you get you
get uh
noticed and approached quite a bit yeah
happened to hearing that but people
people think they know you
because they they know what they know a
certain side of you that is on the
internet
and so there's like one way familiarity
so people come up to you
as though they they've known you your
entire life but you don't have any clue
who this person is they're still a
complete stranger to you so that that
polarity of familiarity is what creates
that kind of fanboy dynamic right yeah
so if you've ever found yourself asking
mark
is it tadalafil that you take right
before you have sex with all the
gorgeous women in your life no it's
actually kratom and where do i get that
kratom from
happyhipporples.com and how do i pay for
it well first of all i use my mom's
credit card second of all i use promo
code thick boy with three c's for 20 off
it makes it affordable okay it makes it
something that i feel good about
purchasing
and that helps me
blow women away in the bedroom
as if
i'm a sterling cooper student and we're
talking about getting women here and
becoming the best most masculine guy
that you can be
you know what's important too with
regards to that clothing
oak and stone clothing to be specific
because when i wear shirts like this
a low cut long sleeve body hugging
chest pocket having
navy blue
projecting
type of shirt from oak and stone i feel
good about myself and you know what
women pick up on it and they say
that's a guy who knows how to dress and
all of a sudden
i'm sliding out of my chair and right
into your arms
oakenstoneclothing.com use code hella
for 10 off at checkout and thank me
later when you're beating the ladies off
with an open stone shirt
and and i do think you can talk yourself
out of it it's sort of this default and
it's like so at the same time i have
understanding for that but at the same
time
it to me it often is a signifier of
immaturity or something that it's like
hey man i understand the instinct but
also think the next step beyond that and
and have some basic human decency i was
just listening to a
a clip from andrew tate about how he he
goes uh i've started hiring bodyguards
not for me but for you guys because if
you run up to me all excited and start
screaming my name i have a gun on me you
know you might get shot and i feel like
in that case you know in his case it is
very real because he's going to be in
some of these places around the world
where you don't know i mean anywhere in
the world really could be potentially
dangerous if a guy's you know if you're
well known and somebody's running up to
you
but uh you know basic social skills and
i think a lot of that
what i'm interested i think what you're
a master of and what many guys could
benefit from because i was you know
i have a lot of little points that i
want to get to
drawing from your videos that i just
relate to particularly but
one of them you know it's actually one
that i didn't watch but it was how to
not be a creep essentially or you know
things you can do to not come across
like a creep and i don't think men
the average guy who's coming to me or
not having success with women or you
know again not that i'm a coach but i
can point guys in the right direction
and one of these things is you have to
master basic social skills because
it's an immediate turn off to women and
if you don't have that self-awareness of
how your actions and words are coming
across to both men and women
it's going to undermine you in in
everyday situations and you'll have no
idea why things aren't going your way so
maybe you could talk about the
importance of social skills just the
basic stuff
yeah i mean not not being creepy
is
paramount when it comes to having any
kind of success with interacting with
women
and
i personally
frame it
like
what women interpret is creepy
i like to define as incongruency
incongruence i think it's yeah i think
it's much easier for guys to kind of
understand this concept with their more
logical brain
yeah and i think i categorize
incongruency as okay
are your thoughts your words and your
actions in alignment with one another or
are they out of alignment
right yeah so for example
am i
if i'm trying to
in the bedroom it's actually a perfect
example of
something that can help guys in the
bedroom
if
if i'm in the bedroom and i'm
trying to act
more dominant i'm trying to do dominant
actions let's say let's say let's say
i'm trying to pull a girl's hair right
properly
i'm doing dominant things i'm saying i
might be saying
oh some some dirty talk line which comes
which is like supposed to be kind of
dominant but in my head
i'm thinking oh [ __ ] i hope this works
this this is really scary uh i hope she
really likes me i've never done this
before i'm so nervous yeah okay well
there's an incongruence there the
thoughts don't match the words and the
actions yeah and women especially are
super good at picking up that
incongruency it's like
tiny little things in your body language
which give away your your actual
internal mental state and so if you
think if you're not thinking
you know that you are the [ __ ] man
and
you're a sex beast when you're trying to
pull off this kind of more dominant
stuff in the bedroom
she can pick up on that instantly yeah
and it makes her feel ironically it
makes her feel unsafe
right right and this might make for this
might sound a bit counter-intuitive if
i'm you know trying to do something a
bit physically aggressive like pulling a
girl's hair or maybe choker in the
bedroom right yeah
what makes her
get into that and feel sexy and safe in
that action
is
her knowing that i'm confident
in doing it that i'm
not nervous about doing performing that
action because if a guy is nervous about
doing it to her well then she has a
reason to feel like he's going to [ __ ]
it up
right
like he don't know what he's doing he's
not actually who he says he is he's
acting this dominant way but he doesn't
actually believe it like is this guy
lying to me like all all these paranoid
thoughts can start creeping into her
head just from this tiny little
misalignment in your thoughts and what
you're actually doing
that's an amazing way to put it because
i always you know i'm a big fan of
breaking down words or swapping that out
and going is there a better word for
example
i remember in high school and college
girls would use the term sketchy right
which is sort of an analogous to creepy
but it's i'm like what does that even
mean it's sort of like douchebag you
know and a lot of people will call me
douchebag and it's like i used to take
that personally now i see it's more of a
reflection of
you know there's a there's words you can
swap out it's just basically saying this
guy makes me uncomfortable it's almost
like
the fee you know the male version of
saying you're creepy it's like this guy
does something feels incongruous or i
don't like it whatever it is it's it's
an emotional reaction and
i really like that notion of incongruity
because
when you think about okay if you're a
sociopath or like women are have to be
equipped with much more sensitive
calibration
to sort of dark triad traits or somebody
who's going to take advantage or even
you know the other end of that somebody
who's particularly weak but but trending
not to because that is a life that could
lead them to a life or death situation
where
if you say
you have the skills to protect her or
the confidence to fight somebody off and
then you don't that's a very dangerous
situation so that all makes sense in a
very primal evolutionary
sense and
i
can just relate to
when you discover as a guy that
like
for example because this mainstream
narrative and what you're fed as a guy
growing up in america and probably many
other places too is like don't you know
you just had a
video about how to treat a woman like an
object it sounds misogynistic it sounds
terrible but really when that's an
authentic expression for you as a
confident man right physical aggression
the grunting the choking the slapping
all these things that are in the context
of of course yes this woman sexually
attracted you and giving you consent and
that might even be something that you
talk about beforehand just to make sure
but
in that bubble of of consent and
understanding
to display these things such as
aggressive or you know things that
outside of that might get considered
toxically masculine or whatever you want
to put on that right it's something that
you have to sort of
do work as a guide to let go of these
notions that no no like in the right way
in the in the right way girls like that
but authenticity is key to that and and
when you get in touch with that as a guy
these authentic expressions of sort of
your caveman self especially in the
bedroom but in other places too because
i think
you know many men could probably do good
to get in touch with like a healthy
notion of competitive you know
competition with other men and being
aggressive being assertive being
extroverted all these things that would
help you for example in
business or most fields
in other arenas you're shamed for those
expressions but you know in the bedroom
when you get in touch with that you just
start to see that that's what drives
women wild but you really can't fake it
there's certain things that you can't
you know really fake or you'd have to
try much you'd have to be an actor as
good as you are to you know fake fake
the disconnect and actually pull it off
because i think we you know we forget
sometimes it's like women learn these
social skills and have higher social
intelligence at younger ages so they're
just for the most part going to be
advanced and their life depends on
picking up on those little cues
that could mean danger in the future so
it's it's it's uh remarkable how
all these
guys who would get labeled as toxic be
masculine or have all these toxically
masculine traits are the ones that women
are creaming their panties over
and and i think
there there has to come a point for a
lot of guys when unless you sort of grew
up with a dad who
drilled a lot of this stuff into you
yeah
men will that's that's kind of what the
whole uh where do you want to call the
whole manosphere space whatever you want
to call this sort of space of the
internet that i'm kind of a part of yeah
is trying to do it's trying to wake guys
up to just
the reality of human nature yeah because
mainstream media is kind of vested in
teaching you the complete opposite of
what reality is
right because it make like what what
what makes for us a nice stable society
will make compliant
tax slaves is really what makes for a
nice stable society don't don't rock the
boat like we can't have every guy
running around being a playboy because
then there's not going to be any like
nuclear families and the tax system will
collapse and we're all screwed right so
you can't really teach guys
the the things that actually work
you can't you can't teach them and and
another thing to consider is that the if
men
didn't run around buying things for
women or for the approval of women or to
impress women the economy would collapse
in a second
i think that like like all the like in
here in miami all these dudes are out
here buying
buying tables and bottle servers and
stuff
they're not doing it for themselves
they're not doing it but they're doing
it to flex so like so they can attract
beautiful women yeah you know and
and they're same with all the boats out
here all the lambos it's like all this
stuff is so much of the economy is
driven behind the
men's need or desire to
to impress and stand out for
to attract women to attract beautiful
women
and
when you part of what i try to teach is
waking guys up
to the to the real
true female and male nature yeah and you
know what
what disney has taught you since you're
a little kid uh what hallmark romantic
comedies teach you what
stupid sitcoms like friends and all this
kind of stuff teach you is the complete
opposite of
how you should and want and should want
to behave
as a man to actually get what you want
out of life
if i'm if i'm
following
the the mainstream narrative i'm
following like oh be it be a be a nice
guy and and
you know
send her flowers and and chocolates and
love letters on the before i even i've
even met her like try to woo her like it
was the 1950s
well i'm probably not going to get
anywhere
yeah but
and i think a good measure of
is your worldview accurate is
are you getting the results that you
want out of life
if i'm if you're sitting there bashing
your head against the wall and you're
doing the same things and you're not
getting any results well then your world
view is clearly wrong
that's a great i
i get all of my students get results
every single one of them who follows my
advice it works yeah because i know what
i'm talking about i understand the
female body i understand how to biohack
it i understand how i
understand how to how to get how to fix
men's heads because i understand how to
get out of my own head so they can
perform under a high pressure situation
and it's like
to me that is the single biggest
indicator of like
is what somebody is saying
true yeah true true in the sense of it's
like undeniable reality yeah it's almost
like it's baked into the physics of the
universe kind of truth i love that and
i'm a big fan of physics as well because
i love this element of like you can you
can calculate
how fast something will fall from a
certain height and i was like one of my
first mic i didn't i wasn't so much into
chemistry or
biology but i remember going to physics
and just being like oh because it's the
way the world works right and you can
observe that and test it and that theme
throughout my life is just something
where i'm very quick to reject false
authority i mean i wouldn't say that
about
you know problems with authority but but
you go this person isn't being truthful
and honest about how to get from point a
to point b and like you said we see that
a lot
uh in modern society and i was gonna say
when i first heard the term manosphere
it was presented to me by a woman who i
used to be friends with but we actually
had a falling out over jordan peterson
because she was calling him i'm like oh
i found this guy he seems to have some
interesting stuff to say on philosophy
and coming from you know i majored in
politics and in college and so i have a
little bit of a you know way into sort
of
listening to an academic and dissecting
whether or not they're telling the truth
but she was insistent that
for example he was a
misogynist and an anti-semite and i just
kept challenging her i'm like well show
me that sort of in what he said because
i've now listened to 12 hours of him
speaking on these lectures and podcasts
and i don't really see now i might not
agree with everything he says and and
politically
um
you know you get into territory but of
course politics is everything but if you
take somebody sort of like is abortion
right or wrong like these more complex
debates and you and you just get into
sort of the observations of human
reality
right now
you know these guys when you say red
pill that means generally
you know a conservative slant on life
however the things that are most
undeniable to me is
uh human dynamics right the social
interactions specifically between men
and women that as you said if you want
results try anything you want but um
like i'm in fitness and it's like i have
this interest in kind of
exposing people who are frauds and
making things overly complicated and
giving bad advice because that can be
you know both hurtful and a waste of
time um but i've always been interested
in like let's pare it down to like what
is the simplest thing you can do that
actually gets you the most results and i
i see you as the same where it's like
let's cut all the bs it might sound
whatever label word misogynistic sexist
wrong taboo and you know i'm sure you
get this all the time and i've all the
time and those words were very scary to
me just a few years ago i wouldn't
express opinions or even take a stance
or defend somebody because the last it's
like being called a racist you know what
i mean you don't want to be called a
misogynist because
you just assume that's this giant stain
on everything and every girl is going to
believe that but then you sort of
realize it's like no no actually
we're listening to this very vocal
minority um who are trying to shame us
in you know just and look it's a first
person observation i can say well this
has worked with women and this hasn't so
you can't convince me otherwise um you
know compared to some more abstract
debates about you know what should we do
in syria right those are complicated
political questions but when it comes to
the um the politics of human interaction
the manosphere to me which again once
was this presented as like this taboo
ridicule oh my god all these men
thinking that men need rights and this
and that it was portrayed as a very
negative light so i remember being very
cautious like i can't let anybody know
i'm watching these youtube videos
because
uh you know it just was presented in in
such a nefarious way to me
um but the fact of the matter is yes as
an instructor you would make a living if
you were telling people information that
that got them nowhere and so
how do you feel like you
have negative feedback and real like
what is the extent of again we're on the
haters we'll say podcast so dealing with
online criticism and sort of like
compartmentalizing it and and dissecting
it and analyzing it before you throw it
out the window ultimately right um that
is it always going to be an interesting
topic to me and so maybe you could tell
me with the kinds of pushback you deal
and the psychological uh strategies that
you employ to get on with your day and
not care about it
i'll tell you what uh so i actually get
a ton of blowback from the porn industry
interesting and uh
in particular actress actors as well but
mostly actresses well let me just
interject real quick because i remember
watching this video where you
ranked the women you've been with and
and like first of all you were very
polite and courteous to like and like it
wasn't as if you know that's and that's
really why i wanted to talk to you
because i go this guy
he says some shocking stuff but he's not
trying to be a shock jock he's not
trying to uh cause controversy in and of
itself what you're doing is being honest
and you were very in my opinion
diplomatic ranking these women in court
you know here's the experience of having
sex here's what they're like on set and
a bell of danger is an annoying little
brat and you're like this and i like
i was like
like it was one of my the most memorable
videos ever watched because you kind of
like you peeled back something that it
felt wrong to be listening to almost and
you immediately go like oh my god these
girls some of these girls in this video
are probably not happy about this some
of them would be right because remember
you're talking about angela white and
you're like i had a lot of things to say
i'm like but it was cool to get that
insight but
i can see how
you're why you're the only porn star
who's done that because it's not going
to make people happy
oh god no
i am i'm probably one of the most hated
guys in my industry uh
because of what i talk about and what i
teach guys and
you so
you most guys would be shocked to
learn
that the porn industry is run by
feminists
yeah
basically every single girl who works as
a porn actress like in 99 of them would
i would identify as being a feminist
yeah
and so they'll have very very feminist
views
uh just
this this some some guys find it hard to
like piece this together like how the
hell can they possibly have work in this
industry and do what they do and then
still be a feminist forget about that
cognitive dissonance yeah okay cognitive
dissonance but
so
they'll happily you know sort of sell
sell their bodies and and and
so did i like i do that too you know so
it's not like i'm sitting here like
trying to be judgey about it i'm just
calling a spade a spade i'm just saying
the facts you know yeah and uh
when i come in and teach guys like
here's a perfect example actually this
is a really good example
so when i come in and i teach guys how
to be more dominant in the bedroom right
say how to like how to do some of these
more
50 shades of grey style sex acts right
so how to pull a girl's hair properly
how to choke her properly how to slap a
girl in a way that when she obviously
when she wants it
consenting right how to do it in a safe
way that's arousing erotic
okay when i teach guys this kind of
stuff the kind of blow back i get from
the porn industry is is goes along the
lines of oh he's teaching really
dangerous stuff you shouldn't be
teaching this
to the average guy because he's going to
go out and and do harm and uh
grape a woman yeah right i don't want to
use words that might get you
yeah
uh and
i think that's extremely an extremely
interesting
response
from feminists in particular women in my
industry to what i teach because i'm
trying to
i'm
if you look at it realistically i'm
helping women more than i'm helping men
right because for every guy that i help
and every guy that i make a better lover
he's going to have great sex with at
least one woman
if not more
so
all in all i'm helping more women than
i'm that that'll help men right you're
making the world a better place and
that's another i wanted i thought that
while you were talking at certain points
but i go this is actually very much a
net positive to because women want
masculine men who know how to bang them
right bingo and every single one of
these these uh porn stars that will come
after me and criticize me
wants to have sex with the kind like
wants to have the kind of sex that i'm
teaching guys like very dominant with a
very masculine man who takes control
does all those kinky perverted things
she likes to do yeah now their res but
their response is
oh
what if the guy uh is socially awkward
what if he doesn't quite understand it
what if he doesn't doesn't quite do it
properly
and to me i think it's an it's an
interesting
response that
these women
will their default is to assume
that every guy
who is looking to to improve his life
yeah
in some way is a potential it's
basically a rapist
right
the default thought is like if he's
looking
to improve himself in any way shape or
form then he should not know this
information at all i've experienced this
in smaller levels maybe not to that
degree but i've
the first time i remember i
was getting some books on amazon about
pickup and female interaction
and i didn't realize this was like a
public wish list and this girl that i
was hanging out like was was like i was
going gonna buy you a book on amazon and
i saw your wish list and like she was
like come on like you know how to pick
up women and i'm just like like i felt
so caught off guard first of all because
it was like the last thing you know it's
like almost like somebody like opens
your porn collection you're like really
you know bbw you're like well i i you
know how do i i didn't even have time to
formulate a defense of myself but uh
what it told me was
this person was so shocked that i would
go seek out any even if i was already i
was moderately successful with women i
had girlfriends but i knew i'm like uh i
could be doing better and there seems to
be like a lot to learn just as far as
strategies from meeting women who you
don't you're not already in a social
circle with really is what guys go to
pick up for it's like okay yeah if you
don't have hot friends who have hot
friends like you're screwed because you
see that hot girl at the mall and you're
too scared to pick her up like or talk
to her
you know it's a deal breaker it's a dead
end so i remember that reaction she was
like
shocked disgusted appalled at the idea
of like my self-improvement right and
throughout my life in addition to that
i've
just seen women stigmatize the notion of
learning like it should all you should
be a master in bed but it also should be
completely instinctual and just a
natural extension of what uh you know a
bad boy you are and you were born that
way with a leather jacket sunglasses and
a 12-inch dock
and uh you know any any striving to
fix your situation
is to be shamed but i like i mean yeah
let's continue i just wanted to
interject that to go like holy [ __ ]
you're right and i hadn't thought about
it in those terms and didn't realize
that it existed like that in the porn
industry i'll explain for you listeners
why that is their reaction too and it's
basically and basically everyone will
have this reaction to men's self-help in
general yeah
if she's if she's with a guy who is who
she's considers attractive and she finds
out that oh
he he learnt something to get this way
he wasn't this way his whole life yeah
right
she will feel duped in some way here's
the reason why
and this is not it's not a very pc thing
of me to say
so
women are inherently kind of born with
their value
right if a woman is beautiful she like
she's she's born with beauty
a woman doesn't have to work
to achieve that
genetic perfection she is she was
literally just born with it right and
that's why men find are attracted to her
and want to to sleep with her right
men on the other hand are born with
[ __ ] nothing
and they have to build
themselves up they have to build their
body like like you obviously hit the gym
all the time that took
years that didn't happen like you
weren't born like that you know you have
to build up your wealth that takes time
and energy and focus and
and commitment to actually build up
resources build up a network a social
network to become the kind of guy who's
charming
and you know and sophisticated and
classy these all take time investments
for a man to kind of reach this point
where he's a very very attractive
mate prospect for a woman right but
women they don't have to put that effort
in and
women by nature are what you would call
philip
yeah so they have they love that word
yeah it's my favorite one of my favorite
words yeah
if anyone who's not familiar with that
with what that word means it basically
means your world solipsism is your
worldview centers around yourself
it's a very self-centered uh you view
the world through the lens of yourself
and it's hard for you to imagine how
anyone else could have a different
perspective right
bingo bingo and so for them it's like
okay they assume that they literally
assume that every attractive man has
kind of always been that guy yeah he's
always been the successful dude
yeah and they they can't really the idea
that he wasn't successful at some point
and he got to that stage through work
and hard effort is almost like they they
feel like they've been duped and they've
been lied to in some way which is why
they have this really because they can't
imagine it because for them it's like
well i've always been beautiful surely
he's always been attractive right they
can't see the difference from they can't
see it from a man's
uh worldview perspective they can only
see it from the female perspective so
then they feel like they've been they've
been lied to in some way even though the
guy even though the guy even though
she's attracted to the guy even though
she's into the guy
yeah i love that breakdown that makes
total sense to me and reminds me again
to you know be fair
when i used to assume that as a teenager
women had the exact same perspective on
the hierarchy of attractive qualities
that appearance should be first or that
if i
you know look a certain way my body
looks a certain way that should make me
paramount you know in the eyes and so
it's harder right you're like wait an
older guy but i'm younger and more buff
and yeah you know so that right that
really shows the matrix of
when you start to understand all the
other things in the hierarchy for what
women find attractive but yes that
i love that breakdown of i think that's
one of the yeah i think that's one of
the main reasons
one of the main causes of
relationship problems or like
conflict between men and women
is
women thinking men see the world that
women see it and men thinking that women
see the world the way the world see the
world the way men see it like
both sexes are kind of
assuming the other sex sees the world
exactly the same way they
yeah and you're reminding me i was going
to say something earlier about how um
number one
if you're not getting results if you're
being told this is an effective way to
do things and this is going to get you
the girl and then it doesn't what does
that create frustrated incels right you
know so that's obviously a big negative
outcome that you're helping to fix just
to you know reiterate that you are in
fact doing a great service even though
you might be
labeled things that that are you know
negative and destructive
um and then
secondly
what i also love about the manosphere is
it's not just it's not about
chauvinism it's not about saying men are
inherently better although you might be
able to say men are inherently better at
certain things on average right
well you can't dunk a basketball like
lisa leslie okay
like not you know not individually but
if you take the aggregate um we can make
certain empirical observations about the
differences in gender for the most part
and
part of
as and i love how you put it too that
you have to as a man build your own
value whereas
um we're just on different timetables
and different strategies to maximize
your value as a woman versus a man
and um
you know
when you are attempting to get better at
picking up women you have to get inside
the mind of a woman and i know it's
possible for women to get inside the
mind of a man and actually do know
although there's this you know cliche
that don't ask a fish you know how to
catch fish if you're a fisherman right
for the most part women can be
uninformed and sort of not be able to
really articulate what they find
attractive or might even be worried to
because if you're talking to a guy who
doesn't have those qualities and saying
like he needs to be the opposite of you
in order for me to be attractive maybe
that feels rude but i do feel like there
are some like melanie king is an example
of one where i watch her content and she
would um
cover i'm forgetting his name but the
guy who just passed the the black guy
who is the image consultant um who is oh
kevin samuels kevin says yeah i feel bad
about blanking on his name but she would
cover him in a positive light because
again i always looked at him
as this lightning rod of controversy and
i'm like but he's making complete sense
and the only things he's asking women to
rate themselves and you're mad about it
you know um
like so it's just but you see i love
seeing stuff like that because i go oh
right
a man who's calmly telling a woman the
truth about herself and pointing out the
notion that she possibly could be
thinking delusionally as far as you know
how she rates herself in comparison to
the rest of the world which to me
indicates a big ego issue what is ego
like it's you know if your ego's out of
whack it means you can't assess yourself
realistically and therefore
anytime you're not getting what you
think you deserve it has to be everybody
else's fault because there must be a a
scheme a plot a conspiracy against you
if you're if you have this amazing value
nobody's recognizing it so um i do think
the manosphere tends to promote that's
all a long-winded way of saying the
manuscript promotes men understanding
women
and
not
there isn't as
i wonder what the mechanism would be for
women to understand men because when you
do meet a woman who understands or tries
to understand
a perspective life perspective
from a guy's point of view
it goes a long way right and can be
instrumental in a harmonic relationship
absolutely and the the the problem
though is you need there has to be some
kind of an incentive
yeah for her
or a woman to want to understand the
world from a man's point of view like we
have a man men have the incentive
to want to understand
women right yeah
and that incentive is you get laid
basically right
right but
where's the incentive for women to
really understand and mend a lot more
into in especially you know in america
in the western world in general yeah
that incentive is kind of
uh taken away because you have
things like
like
divorce courts and child like child
custody laws and a bunch of different
laws that are in place yeah which
are very skewed heavily skewed against
men yeah and they sort of put they put a
lot of
uh they they reward women a lot with
without any real responsibility yeah
right they get or they give them a lot
of we'll say they give them a lot of
authority yeah yeah and that's something
you were talking about
that i thought was such a great point
was um
and not that you know i've seen many
people of different genders abuse power
but you said in a video that i was just
watching
when women get in positions of
power
you know concentrated power and have
no
uh responsibility or checks on their
power they tend to become petty tyrants
and then again that sounds you know
another thing is like whoa whoa
misogynistic alarm bells going off but
we've all witnessed it you know
my exact words
to give guy to give your viewers a
context of that it's so i i i learned
this when i uh yeah when i started you
know helping guys out on the internet uh
i started shooting less pornography
instead of getting more into the youtube
space and helping guys
i
would would get attacks from uh my
former co-stars female co-stars on
twitter and what i was observing was
okay you've got this you've got these
women
think about think about her reality for
a second so
18 19 year old girl
she has half a million followers on her
social media account let's just say just
on a twitter right
she her her experience of being on a
pawn set this is what this what her
reality is like as a female actress on
in porn right
every guy she interacts with on a daily
basis tells her she can do no wrong yeah
right because she she gets to set right
the makeup lady is is sitting there
doing her makeup telling her she looks
so pretty trying to get her in a good
mood
uh
me the co-star i don't want to piss her
off in any way shape or form because if
i piss her off or anyone on set pisses
her off she might walk off set and then
the director's down a few thousand
dollars and he hates me
right
with a pissed her off right so everyone
is the whole day everyone is basically
massaging her ego trying not to piss her
off right she's the cube
yeah so she's the she's she is literally
the product of porn yeah like i'm just
there to make the scene i'm there to
make the scene go but people buy it for
her yeah and by the way that quote was
in the context now that i'm thinking of
it i think it there is a universal to it
but you were specifically talking about
on porn sets you know you're making a
great case for why this is and if guys
were treated like that you'd probably
see more of that too but in this
particular case like your experience
leads to that and you're saying you
would get attacked and
yeah you know and that they they would
take they will take uh so 18 year old
girl every time she interacts with a man
in in in this industry he's he's either
blown smoke up her ass or telling her
she can do no wrong so then she gets a
she she has a ping of like negative
emotion because she disagrees with
something on social some words
on social media so what does she do
yeah she takes her
her throng of
white knight
soyboy followers and directs that army
of hate
at somebody yeah to get the
quote-unquote cancelled yeah and i think
that's and it's it's like
or you could just like
log off of twitter and not and or
unfollow me but
it's this sort of like righteousness of
like someone has offended me
they must be punished in some way right
it's a very narcissistic response and
that's again
you know if i hadn't been humbled at
certain ages you know you think back
it's just like the experiences that i've
had of not having that i'm sure i would
have been a tyrant too if you gave me
all of that at the age of 18 and just
told me it was god's gift to everything
and nobody was ever criticizing me
luckily i was playing college football
and on a daily basis told how much i
suck on video in slow motion you know so
that's uh enough all right i can handle
some criticism but absent of that i
think it's just very important for the
human experience because as you're
saying yes then it then it becomes it's
not just about your idea of yourself
right it's like cool you want to be
privately delusional
the the ethical issues come in when
you're narcissistic and egotistical and
then when somebody disagrees with you
the damage that you feel justified in
doing to them because your lack of
self-awareness makes you incredibly
self-righteous and vicious towards the
wrong people and in the wrong direction
um so that's that's a great little
anecdote i think beautifully we'll be
wrapping up here pretty soon um i try to
keep these to an hour although i could
talk to you you know i could bug you and
question you about everything for hours
and hours you know and i'm sure that's
on the top of your list is to talk to
mark harley about uh how you got an
email escorting but um man you can ask
me anything you like
yeah no and i know that and i'm still
good sometimes yes i i feel that and uh
and i love that i was just gonna maybe
kind of
close off by
asking you about uh the pro i remember i
think the first time i heard about you
might have been with regards to
the sexual dominance hierarchy is that
what it's called your program then i was
like oh my god it's this much money but
then i was like well actually if this
delivers on what he says it delivers
like becoming a master of of sex in a
way that drives women wild and not many
men have the skill i'm like oh yeah
that's it's not going to be this you
know 49 ebook it's gonna be something a
little bit more expensive but worthwhile
so
maybe you could you know i'm not asking
for any free game per se but maybe you
could just uh because i'd love to be
repitched on it and
maybe i'm going to go home and buy it
after all but for for guys
who are out there listening who again
don't know your content that well maybe
you could give them a little preview or
give us a little pitch on what some of
the things are uh that you
include in that program and some of your
you know the things that you cause
there's like hundreds of videos as i
said before uh before we started filming
you have so much amazing content on
youtube about all these different topics
but the stuff that's behind the paywall
i assume you feel like it's really worth
it
well absolutely and it's and
i've literally like saved marriages and
saved relationships with with this stuff
it's
like when you
i'm extremely proud of you know this
video course you're talking about
because it's
it's been so impactful guys and the way
i kind of structured it was
i i wanted i wanted to be able to take
what's in my head
right and download it into someone
else's brain yeah that's kind of what i
that was my goal
how can i take
like how can i take a guy who is like
shy
nerdy insecure uh not confident in
himself in the bedroom very timid right
with limited sexual experience how could
i take this guy and then basically turn
him into me
like a complete
stevie sexual deviant and this is this
is what i came up with
i i try basically
baby step guys on on like a scale from
like zero being super vanilla and tame
to like a hundred being you know you
could get into a you could get into a
bdsm dom sub relationship if you wanted
to right and i try to baby step guys
along this kind of spectrum yeah
because one of the one of the most
important things about and i kind of
touched on this before when we talked
about congruency one of the most
important things about
pulling off some more extreme things in
the bedroom
is
is it's
less about her comfort level and it's
more about
your comfort level if you're not
comfortable if i if i want to tie a girl
up for example like with some shibari
bondage
phone entire hands and her legs together
and string her up from the ceiling well
if i if i'm not confident in it then she
sure as hell ain't going to be confident
i think it should work yeah i know the
ceiling should be strong enough how
much
no yeah we'll put a pad down there just
in case uh
so i think so i basically like to teach
guys like from
like i try to make my uh my stuff i
sounds bad but i try to make it autistic
proof
that's such a great phrase my god
you're you're a true wordsmith
i'll i'll break i'll break what to some
to some people is a really
natural and
energy feeling kind of experience and
i'll try to break it down logically into
like okay what exactly
am i doing here right yeah a lot of guys
need that a lot of guys do need that
step by step because they lack emotional
and social intelligence but i do think
you can you know
and they lack that
they like that experience yeah of seeing
a woman react positively and that's
something i've had i've heard a lot of
guys talk say in response to this stuff
is
i could never have imagined myself doing
these things
until you taught me yeah right so if i
for example if i'm teaching a guy
like how to choke a girl properly right
i mean for for a start
avoid the windpipe fellas it's not you
don't want to it's not making that
mistake
we're not crushing an empire we're like
we're squeezing on the sides here like
that's the first key lesson in learning
how to choke a girl probably
and
what i do and and part of the reason why
i have to put the stuff behind a paper
is i actually use i it's me and a couple
of like real life porn stars
demonstrating everything
in in real time real life i can't put
this stuff on youtube
because it would
it violates their terms you know it's
rude bits are not allowed
on
youtube right but i can sit there and i
can show you guys okay
here's how you actually penetrate a
woman at a certain angle you say you're
like you lift her hips up like this or
you get her on top of you and cowgirl
and you move her in this certain way so
we can get
you know the head of your penis hitting
her g-spot consistently and that's how
we can get into orgasm it's there's
i'm a real nerd i'm still a nerd let's
be honest i'm a real nerd when it comes
to like sex because i break it down
yeah
but that's what we need i always say
like um you know i
tell people i'm a steroid nerd you know
if i'm giving advice on anabolics
because i've i've gone through these
steps myself and some guys aren't into
that and they just want to know like
tell me what to take and it's fine right
but you need guys like you or the best
you know i've been training with michael
hearn recently and he's got this
knowledge of bodybuilding and the
ability to communicate that's the second
part is like you could know all that
and if you're autistic yourself you
probably wouldn't you know know what to
do but or how to communicate it but here
you are and you can actually communicate
it really well and and put yourself in
that person's position so i
uh we're gonna have to run
but
i really really enjoyed our conversation
sterling and i really appreciate you
taking the time and i feel like again i
could i could talk to you for hours
about this stuff it's very fascinating
to me and you are a great communicator
when it comes to this stuff and i think
you make a lot of taboo topics really
accessible to men so why don't you just
tell us where we can find you online i
know but i'll let you do it
uh the the if you want if you want to
digest some of the information that i
gave up for free then go to youtube and
type in sterling cooper i'm the first
and it pops up uh spell my name
correctly though s-t-i-r l-i-n-g yes and
you're still in cooper you'll find me
i'm the first uh result and i have a ton
of free advice there and then if you
want to you know dive into some of the
the paid material that i have some of my
courses and my books and things you can
just go to sterlingcooper.com and you'll
find everything there
amazing well thank you again so much uh
hope you have a great rest your day and
hopefully i'll also be talking to you in
the future for part two let's do it all
right man i appreciate it
you